So, over the last 23 years we've been
studying the center of the galaxy with
the largest telescopes in the world — that's the Keck telescope — and by developing new ways
of using this telescope to get to the
diffraction limit we've been able to
open up a new way of studying
supermassive black holes. That's by
watching the orbits of stars as they
orbit the center of our galaxy, the Milky
Way. These orbits have been able to show that
there is a supermassive black hole at the center of our galaxy. This is the best
evidence to date that supermassive
black holes exist not only in the center
of our own galaxy but anywhere in the
universe
and by continuing to measure the
these orbits — both time and technology helps — we
have the ability to explore the physics
of supermassive black holes.
In other words: Testing how black holes
warp space-time as well as the astrophysics
of supermassive black holes — what role
these objects play in the formation and
evolution of galaxies. This is the only galaxy in
which we can watch this interaction that
we think is key in the evolution of the
universe at play